Metro Sheriff Kevin mcmahill delivering
his first state of the department
address this morning he discussed
investing in his officers to inspire
them to invest in a community pointing
out that improving the community starts
within the department
injecting Humanity in the way that we
treat one another because if we don't
get it right internally
we're never going to get it right
externally already been remarkable plans
to increase benefits for the department
and focusing on their health both
mentally and physically we'll have much
more in his thoughts about police reform
coming up this afternoon at 4 5 and 6.